शीघ्र नमस्कार आपका स्वागत है जर्मन सीखिए
हिंदी में कि नए एपिसोड
कि पिछली बार हमने देखा कि छोटे-छोटे
सेंटेंस हम जरूर में कैसे बनाते हैं और व
को कैसे कंजूस सेट करते हैं कैसे चलाते
हैं आज हम देखेंगे कि जर्मन अल्फाबेट्स
कैसे हम उनका उच्चारण करते हैं तो क्रश
लुट जर्मन फिर शुरू करते हुए हमको एक
फायदा यह है कि हमारा पचास परसेंट काम तो
आलरेडी हो गए हैं क्यों क्योंकि हमको
वॉल्यूम इट्स लिखने आते हैं जैसे मराठी वह
या हिंदी हो यह एक लिपि जो देवनागरी लिपि
है वह शहर करते हैं वैसे ही सारी यूरोपीयन
लैंग्वेजेस मोस्ट दें वह शेयर करते हैं
रोमन लगी तो अगर आपको यह अंग्रेजी पढ़ना
आता है तो आपको जर्मन में पड़ता है पर
उसके उच्चार अलग है वह बच्चा कैसे अलग है
वह अभी हम सीखेंगे
है तो शुरू करते हैं मेरे पास आप भी बोलिए
तो आपको भी आसानी होगी
हुआ था आ
ए बेबी
में नियुक्त
कर दे
के लिए के लेफ्ट गेई
जी हां यही
अरे यार
झाल जी एम
कि एन
हाउ टो बे दोष और इस
मेरा टैब ओम साहू वेब
का सिक्स सिक्सेस अलार्म सेट
फोटो कॉपी देखा होगा कि सिर्फ दो ही जगह
पर बहुत ज्यादा डिफरेंस है वह कौन से हैं
जो इंग्लिश का ने जो इंग्लिश का जे है वह
जर्मन में डोंट वांट अगर आपको ने बचपन में
देखा होगा तो साउथ अफ्रीका का एक प्लेयर्स
हैंसी क्रोनिए करके तो कमेंट कर दो उसको
करेंगे बुलाते थे पर जब पेपर में लिख दिया
था वह क्रोंजे होता था तो उस टाइम तो हमें
कुछ समझ में नहीं आता तो फिर उसका रिवीजन
है कुछ यूरोपीय भाषाओं में चेक का उच्चार
यह होता है वैसे ही खूबसूरत हैं अगर आप
उसका स्पेयरिंग देखोगे शोरूम्स पर तो वह
Vivo पर उसका उच्चारण अब हिंदी में नीचे
उसको तो होगा ऑफिसर क्योंकि वी का उच्चार
जर्मन में होता है पाऊं तो यह सिर्फ योट
और बहू अगर आप छोड़ दो तो बाकी के ऊंचाहार
एकदम हिंदी जहां इंग्लिश जैसे ही है
अरे सिमिलर टू इंग्लिश अभी यह हो गया 26
अल्फाबेट्स इन के बाद जर्मन में और चैनल
फट वह कौन से हैं हम देखते हैं पहला है
ऊपर दौड़ उनको बोलते हैं उनको उसका
उच्चारण है आई आई फिर ओके ऊपर डाट उसका
उच्चारण जो यह तीसरा है उनके ऊपर दो नॉट
उसका उच्चारण फिर यून जू
है और चौथा है एसिड उसको भूलते हैं जैसे
बेटा की तरह लिखा जाता है उसका उच्चारण
जैसे साफ वालों के से या फिर डबल ऐड तो
पहले अंग्रेजी वाले 26 और यह चार टोटल
अपडेट्स होंगे 31
यहां पर जर्मन में और चार स्वर भी है इनको
होते हैं संयुक्त स्वर मतलब क्या दूसरे
कतराते हैं एक साथ आते हैं और उनका नया
स्वर्ग बन जाता है हम देखेंगे आ और उन्हें
गुस्सा था कि बनता है आओ जैसे कि अवधी है
और फिर भी और एक साथ आखिर बनता है ईद
दीर्घावधि जी फिर
कि यह और एक साथ आकर बनता है आई आई जैसे
माई
है और एकूण एक साथ आकर बनता है और ऑयल
जैसे ऑयल रोएगी चार संयुक्त स्वर हम बनाते
हैं तो आज हम ने सीखे 30 अल्फाबेट्स और
चार संयुक्त स्वर अभी इस पर एक और मजेदार
बात है दोस्तों आज हम सीखेंगे तो जैसे
हिंदी जब हम बोलते हैं तो हर जगह थोड़ी
अलग-अलग बोली जाती है जिससे उत्तर प्रदेश
महाराष्ट्र गुजरात थोड़ी थोड़ी अलग होती
है जब हम हिंदी सीखते हैं तब हम हिंदी
सीखते हैं
है वैसे ही जर्मन बोली जाती है जर्मनी
ऑस्ट्रिया और स्विट्जरलैंड ने जर्मनी
ऑस्ट्रिया और स्विट्जरलैंड ने पर हर जगह
थोड़े अलग-अलग डायलेक्ट्स बोले जाते हैं
जर्मनी के अलग-अलग राज्यों में भी
यहां पर हम जब सीखेंगे तो हॉट टॉयज प्रमाण
जर्मन सीखेंगे और उसके कुछ खासियतें हैं
उसमें सिर्फ दो सबसे इंपोर्टेंट है वह आज
हम सीखेंगे सबसे पहले जो है कि अगर एक
शब्द के एंड में अगर इगे आता है कि यह तो
उसका उपचार हम करते हैं जैसे बिल दिल से
मैं अभी जहां मैं रहता हूं बायल वहां पर
उसका उपचार भी लिख होता है बिल्कुल पर हम
ब्रिटिश कि सीखेंगे दूसरा महत्वपूर्ण है
से हाथ या फिर सीखिए तो यह छह है उसका
नॉर्मल उपचार होता है इस तरफ इस हमने सीखा
है और जब यह आ पाऊंगा
है तो यह उसके बाद जाएगा आ ओमे यह उसके
बाद जाएगा तब उसका उच्चारण होगा कि मैं
एक्सांपल देता हूं माखन माखन भूख earn ओके
सिंपल है अगर इन चारों के बाद ही करना या
फिर शो करना और आप जैसे-जैसे सीखते जाओगे
यह आपको आसान होता जाएगा
अच्छा ठीक है तो आज हमने जर्मन अल्फाबेट
सीखें एक बार सारे हम रिवाइज्ड करते हैं
आप भी मेरे साथ बोलो आ बे अमेज्ड
को शेयर डे ढेर
के लिए के रस लीजिए हाय आई
अरे यार हुआ था एलजी एम
कि एन एन ओ पे ज़ख्म ए गर्ल एस टेल कुंग
पाओ वे फिक्स ईपी 9
मैं आऊं
और भी
कि आई और मुझे आशा है आप सब लोगों को
जर्मन अल्फाबेट ठीक से समझ में आए होंगे
नेक्स्ट पार्ट में हम सिर्फ 18 में शब्द
सीखेंगे कितने 18 और हम सारे जर्मन नंबर्स
कमेंट करना सीखेंगे तो मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट
एपिसोड में धन्यवाद